Oh
well we do live in a culture that does
send beams out the message more is
usually better the high-tech solution is
the best solution what we don't often do
is watch and wait
particularly with drugs post-marketing
to see that once something becomes in
more widespread use then you begin to
see the downside you see low-level
negative effects now if you're somebody
who's got cancer and you need a
chemotherapy drug you know there are
some downsides to chemotherapy drugs but
you've got a really clear benefit that
you're hoping for in fact some studies
show efficacy for some of these drugs
it's very impressive
if you're somebody who has a condition
for which the solution is not
necessarily proven to be that
efficacious which probably has more of a
downside than you can see particularly
if it's a new solution a new drug or new
treatment it's usually better to watch
and wait
there are many parents for example who
looked at the fact that the HPV vaccine
was largely studied in older women 15 16
to 25 yet it's being marketed for the 9
to 12 year old girls out there because
of course it's not effective if you get
to a young woman after she's been
sexually active so there's reason for
this targeting of very young girls but
their parents have said you know there's
only a few hundred women and those few
hundred girls in those clinical trials
I'm gonna watch and wait because I don't
want my daughter to be a guinea pig and
in fact that's what it is if you're
dealing with a product of vaccine or
anything else we're in the large
clinical trials your particular group
you're looking at and these are 9 to 12
year old girls weren't representative in
the sample in those studies and that's
the kind of thing that we encourage our
our constituencies to listen for to look
for where's the evidence does it really
have to be taken this drug this
procedure does it have to be done now
can you watch and wait and we also want
to caution women about elective
procedures so many women are jumping on
the cosmetic-surgery bandwagon there's a
lot of promotion for the latest form of
surgery it's even gotten to the point of
labiaplasty and vaginal rejuvenation and
ridiculous approaches that in fact main
some
that have really questionable benefits
and cost a lot of money these are things
you have to pay out-of-pocket for
because medical insurance of course
won't cover elective cosmetic surgery
and women are being duped into thinking
their lives will be made better and
women think if they get augmentation
breast augmentation and they get the
latest silicone gel breast implant
suddenly their lives will be a whole lot
better well you know they might feel
better about how that part of their body
looks if they aren't one of the women
who have a problem post-surgery but the
studies show that overall you're not
happier with your life just because you
do breast augmentation the things about
your life how your personal life goes
how your job is going your relationship
with your friends those things don't
change because you get breast
augmentation even though you think they
might and it's that kind of social
science research we want women to
recognize and we want their partners to
recognize - I met a boyfriend in a
college campus who pleaded with his
girlfriend not to get breast
augmentation
he said she was perfectly fine he had
done some research on the Internet
beyond the ads sent the plastic surgeon
websites and he could see these were
some significant risks and he didn't
want his girlfriend taking them and her
response to him when he pleaded with her
not to undergo breast augmentation was
you know everybody in my sorority is
doing it so I've got to do it too and he
said to me he said that's when I
realized that a boyfriend's opinion only
goes so far it's the culture that's
teaching women messages about their
bodies and it's the culture that's
encouraging what he believed were risky
practices
well I think the omnipresent of the
media and the nature of the media it's
gotten more violent more sexually
violent access to pretty violent
pornography is readily available to very
young children boys and girls and
parents who think their kids don't have
access to the material are sorely misled
there are parents now learning to ask
their children not to eliminate the
cache they go in and look at what their
kids are looking at sometimes because
they're learning some amazing things the
fact is that we will not be able to
offset this incredible impact of mass
media except insofar as we talk about
these issues we bring the conversation
to the dinner table we watch some of
these things with our kids that we ask
our kids to become better deconstructors
of media the there are so many
misogynistic messages that lead even
young women to think about themselves in
pejorative ways that it's scary to me as
someone who didn't grow up with all this
around me I was more protected from it I
think that the worst I could do was go
into my uncle's closet and find his
stash of Playboy magazines and flip
through them but I didn't see the kind
of really violent pornography that's out
there and steady fair and especially for
young men who then expect certain things
of young women they become involved with
they they consider this normal and
routine and I know if some filmmakers
are taking this on I will say that one
of the roots to educating young people
about all of the misinformation and
sometimes the strange ideologies that
become embedded in our brains without
our realizing it is to really follow the
talented young documentarians who are
trying to get at some of these problems
they're getting at the food supply
they're getting at pornography they're
getting at sexuality they're getting at
all manner of issues that I consider
social problems now but they're doing
with good humor they're doing it through
interviews through personal storytelling
they're really finding a way to grab the
attention of young people who are
bombarded with messages from everywhere
you know it's everything from
texting in apps and you know for your
phones and you know that your favorite
programs which of course you can see at
any time of day through TiVo or on the
Internet
you can literally be saturated with
media that may or may not be inclusive
of correct information accurate
information just take tobacco and women
for example there are so many attractive
characters in movies and television
shows who are smoking all the time
10-15 years ago that wasn't the case so
though we know a lot about tobacco use
and certainly you know some women
certainly know that lung cancer is the
leading cause of cancer mortality and
women it's not breast cancer or
something else nonetheless we see rates
of smoking rising among young women
older teens women in their early 20s
even when they're bit better educated it
used to be a socioeconomically linked
problem now I think something's happen
with the media and its impact on very
smart young women that you see more of
them smoking it's also tied in with the
obsession with thinness in this culture
a little weight on your body is a good
thing the important thing is to eat well
to get some exercise you know to feel
good and where your body lands in terms
of weight is where it probably ought to
be but the obsession with body weight
with thinness what the hourglass figure
has led to a kind of starvation approach
to eating for many women and in a kind
of obsession with food and body type
that makes it impossible for young women
to have healthy lifestyles and that's
part of what we're up against is we've
got media selling all kinds of
starvation diets ideas all kinds of
ideas about body image that really run
against the grain of what's healthy and
we need sane voices wherever they can be
found on the internet occasionally in a
community setting who'll say stop
wait and our favorite actually our
favorite advice to young girls is don't
buy the standard glossy magazines filled
with ads and articles that will lead you
to self-loathing they will lead you to
body hating
instead don't read them throw them away
if you're young yet magazines like teen
voices magazines that are explicitly
about rejecting these mainstream media
messages that lead us to be totally
dissatisfied with who and what we are
that lead us to be primarily consumers
of products and procedures rather than
contributors to our community to society
you know people with brains and ideas
and people who can make great
contributions to making this world a
better place if we're spending all our
time dieting and buying every single
product Under the Sun and analyzing all
these ads in the magazines that we read
we don't have time to join the community
efforts that make this world a better
place
there's no question that it's an eighth
among human beings to want to adorn our
bodies to want to wear interesting
clothes to pierce our bodies to do all
kinds of things that make us look
interesting different to make a a
signature statement there is nothing
wrong with that unless we start doing
things that really pose significant harm
to our health and then we should be
doing only with our eyes open and that's
where for example with fashion I know
some teenagers who decided to put on
their own fashion show and they design
their own clothes but they weren't
proposing that women get up in very high
heels which are really bad for your feet
number one they weren't proposing that
women wear constrictive clothing that
makes it really hard to move around or
clothing that they didn't feel good and
they they chose clothing they felt
really good in and they chose clothing
that would be reasonable in terms of
what somebody could produce wouldn't be
so totally expensive that only rich
people could afford it I mean that's
part of the problem is that we've
created a culture where everybody is
supposed to aspire to or emulate the
most expensive thing on the market or
what the very rich folks are doing
rather than what really would be fun for
us and it might not be what rich folks
are doing it might be what we think it
looks good feels good and it goes that
the same goes for food I mean we can
bring locally can grown vegetables that
taste great even to the inner-city and
we're doing that with projects that
prove you can get really good food tasty
food and you don't have to buy plastic
food filled with with chemicals that are
actually known to harm our health